Hi, I am Phil Sly.
I'm the pastor of Discipleship and Community here at Henderson Hills,
and we're looking at, uh, community group training.
This is a philosophical and passionate and practical approach to how we can do
community groups better.
And this video we'll be looking at the community group missions discipleship
coordinator, and we can agree that in a consumerist world,
it's often driven by self-interest and personal gain.
And so the concept of Christian service and relational discipleship
stands in contrast as a powerful reminder to the true essence of
faith. And so, uh,
we can live sent by sending disciples from our community group to love and
to serve in homes, in ministries, in neighborhoods, in the city,
and even across the nations.
And so the role of the Mission Discipleship coordinator is to challenge
community group members to live sin.
We call our community group people to participate in missions opportunities and
to encourage micro group involvement. So in this video,
we're gonna highlight three sections. Number one,
we're gonna look at scriptural support for missions and discipleship
involvement. Number two,
I'm gonna show you a list of Henderson Hill's mission's opportunities.
And then lastly,
we're gonna look at a process for encouraging micro group involvement. So let's,
first of all look at scriptural support for missions and discipleship. Uh,
this first passage is, uh, grounded in the teachings of Jesus.
And Jesus taught us that serving others is cherished by God.
In Matthew 25 35, it says, uh, I was hungry and you gave me food.
I was thirsty, and you gave me drink. I was a stranger, and you welcomed me.
I was naked, and you clothed me. Now, remember,
this is Jesus sharing the parable that expresses how serving others literally
blesses him, blesses God. And when I was in prison,
you came to me and the righteous and him will answer saying,
when did that happen? When did we feed you?
When did we give you something in the drink? When did we clothe you?
And listen to this in verse in the final verse 40, it says,
truly I say to you as you did it to one of the least of these my
brothers, you did it to me. So Jesus is emphasizing that, uh,
that this is a significant to obey God's mission, John,
not just for obedience sake,
but we act in engages and we engage acts of charity by feeding
the hungry and providing water and caring for those less fortunate.
These are actions that are deeply cherished by God. As a matter of fact,
when these things are done to the least of his people, it's done to him.
Number two, serving others is exemplified by Christ. In Mark 10 45,
uh, Jesus said, for even the son of man did not come to be served,
but to serve and to give his life as a ransom for many.
So Jesus sets the ultimate example of service Through his own life,
the gospel speaks of his death, burial, and resurrection.
Why would we expect different from ourselves?
His sacrificial love for us demonstrates that genuine service
involves putting others' needs before one's own needs.
And so when Christians follow Jesus' example, they embraced Christ's heart.
They have a servant's heart that draws,
draws them closer to Christ and understands the essence of his teachings.
They experience personal transformation and they shed selfish desires.
They find joy in making a positive impact on others. Next,
serving others is the solution for selfishness. In Galatians five 13,
the apostle Paul says, for you are once called to freedom brothers only.
Do not use your freedom as an opportunity for the flesh,
but through love serve one another.
Paul's letter to the gr to the Galatians remind us that true service is, uh,
rooted in love and in humility.
And if we will humbly serve and love one another's, then uh,
we'll learn to overcome our own personal selfishness. It, uh,
it serves to nurture a spirit of gratitude,
and it acknowledges that all we have comes from God serving shares
those blessings with others. It not only blesses them,
but it literally strengthens our own faith and our own relationship with Jesus.
And two other things,
serving others as to the Lord will be rewarded now serving, uh,
to receive a reward that's the least possible of motivations. However,
Ephesians, uh, Ephesians 6, 7 8, Paul says,
rendering service with a goodwill asked to the Lord and not to man,
knowing that whatever good anyone does this,
he will receive back from the Lord.
So by serving wholeheartedly and selflessly, Paul says, we will receive back.
Now, we don't know exactly what that recept reception will look like,
but we can understand that our serving to the Lord is an offering, and it,
it elevates the Lord and it teaches us and gives us a,
a greater sense of eternal significance. Uh,
next serving others exercises, spiritual gifts.
Peter said in one Peter four 10 that, uh, uh,
Christian gifts are given, uh, Christians are given unique gifts and talents,
and those are meant to be used to serve others. He said,
each of you should use whatever gift you've received to serve others as
faithful stewards of God's grace.
So when Christians utilize their talents and service,
it reinforces the understanding that our abilities, our talents,
our gifts are given to us by God.
And so exercising these spiritual gifts that enhances our ability to serve,
but it also brings glory to God.
Christian service is not just an act of kindness.
It's a way of life that's deeply rooted in the teachings of Jesus.
And so when Christians selflessly serve others,
they embody the love and compassion and humility that Christ showed.
When Christians serve,
they contribute to creating a more compassionate and loving world,
and they reflect the heart of Jesus to all they serve. Uh,
what I can ask you to do during this video or after this video,
is to actually go onto our website, hhbc.com,
and then put forward slash mission.
And there you'll see a list of opportunities to serve at Henderson Hills.
This is actually a screenshot of the different missions opportunity.
There you can see 12 opportunities for local mission's involvement.
Uh,
we at Henderson Hills believe that our mission is to equip one another to love
Jesus and live sin.
So living sin means that we live in such a way to reveal the hope of Jesus
with others. As his ambassador, we, uh,
are reflecting his heart in the way we love.
We are sharing his gospel in the way we speak,
and we take intentional actions to love nonbelievers and literally
get involved in their lives to do life with them. When we do that,
we're showing nonbelievers the hospitality of Jesus.
And our mission focuses both on local missions efforts and on global
missions opportunities. Think about this for a second.
What if your community group decided to, uh,
to take on a global mission trip that you decided as a community group to go to
Nicaragua together, or maybe to go to Morocco or, or to go somewhere where, uh,
you can work with our missions department to discover the destination?
What if you, uh,
helped one another by collecting one another's funds in order to send those who
can go?
What an amazing opportunity it would be to come back and share the story about
how God had used them to take his gospel to the nations. Well,
each of these in these ministries, uh, any community group,
can literally make a, a,
a very powerful significant impact just by offering your time and your
skills and your compassions to support these ministries. And so,
whether you are mentoring at risk youth or teaching English lessons,
or providing essential resources or needs, uh,
or just simply being a friend to someone who needs a friend,
your community group can play a vital role in helping these ministries
fulfill their purpose and serve their communities effectively. One more thing,
and that is I wanna talk to you about a process for encouraging Microgroup
involvement. Now,
a very significant part of the role of the mission's discipleship coordinator is
to encourage micro group involvement. And what that means is that, uh,
that that leader discerns that it's time to pursue a deeper
approach to discipleship.
What you're doing as a community group is discipleship,
but the leader of a discipleship coordination, this,
they have this vision for establishing a disciple making micro group within the
community group. And they make that a priority,
both a men's micro group and a women's micro group,
or multiple men's or multiple women's micro groups.
They understand that disciple making micro,
micro groups are the optimal environment for nurturing and equipping disciples.
Now, a micro group is a gender-based group,
and it's called a micro group because it's just got three to five participants.
Four is perfect,
and they provide an ideal setting for intimate spiritual growth. Uh,
look at what involves in a micro group. First of all,
there's increased intimacy.
A smaller gender-based group just naturally fosters deeper connections,
and it allows for more profound spiritual discussions and a greater sense of
belonging when you're gone from a group of four people miss you. Number two,
transparency and even vulnerability. In a close-knit setting,
individuals of micro groups are more comfortable about opening up about their
struggles and their doubts and celebrating their joys and their blessings.
And this vulnerability leads to authentic spiritual growth through
accountability. Uh, there's also a greater responsibility. Uh,
few are members with, uh,
each participant plays a more significant role in the group's discussion and
activities. Like I said, when they're gone, they're missed.
And so that kind of promotes a,
a greater sense of personal responsibility for assisting one another in the
spiritual journey. And then lastly, accountability.
Accountability is the cornerstone of discipleship.
Micro groups provide a built-in system for members to hold one another
accountable in their walk with Christ and seeing one another transforming into
his image. So, uh,
by leading your community group in the implementation of establishing disciple
making micro groups,
you'll be fostering an environment where discipling relationships are nurtured
and can flourish. This is relational disciple making.
Now I'm gonna ask you to fight the temptation to only repeat old
patterns. Uh,
many Christian education patterns evaluate spiritual maturity by
attendance and retention of knowledge. Now,
there is value in attendance and retention of knowledge,
but disciples seek transformation in addition to to
attendance and transformation of knowledge.
Old pattern Christian education strategies revolve around Bible study classes
and theological education. And again,
there's value in bible study classes and in theological education.
But disciples seek in addition to obedience and
accountability in addition to that formal training. So these old patterns, uh,
for every one of us, they're deeply entrenched in our minds. And, uh,
we have to learn the to,
to resist the temptation just to fall back into those patterns because, uh,
the future of micro groups is promising.
If together we will hunger for more of Jesus with a genuine
high interest in spiritual things,
then micro groups will come together and grow in Christ and literally change
the environment of the community group,
the discipleship and community ministry staff.
That would be me and those in the office.
We are more than willing to support you in any way possible to make this vision
a reality.
We're willing and able to organize meetings and to facilitate training and to
help with logistics. We're gonna do whatever we can to help you encourage micro
Group involvement.
So please consider just the immense potential that disciple making micro groups
have for your community group. Uh,
they represent a chance to deepen faith.
They represent a chance to strengthen relational bonds,
and they are probably our very best opportunity for creating
relationships that make disciples. You,
as the missions and discipleship coordinator,
serve as a catalyst to start new groups. The, uh,
mission coordinator encourages new disciple making micro groups in the following
ways. There are five regularly highlight and communicate the
church's vision to becoming a disciple making hub.
Do you talk about that in your community group?
You as a leader will be the one to be bringing that up. Number two,
celebrate people in your group that are involved in micro groups. Currently,
we have about 30 adult community, uh,
micro groups that are meeting off campus during different times of the week.
If you have someone in your community group, ask them about that,
give them an opportunity to share about that. Celebrate the fact that this is a,
a great thing that they're doing because what you celebrate, you replicate.
And we're working at replicating more micro groups. And number three,
you coordinate micro groups participants to share stories about their micro
group involvement. Uh, maybe, uh,
give a time before or after your prayer time to, uh,
share stories and testimonies about what God is doing in your micro groups.
And number four, you encourage existing relationships.
This is probably the most important thing in, uh,
encouraging micro group involvement.
You encourage existing relationships to become intentional about starting
disciple making micro groups. Uh,
what's amazing about our community groups is there are strong relationships
already in place. Uh,
but what we're doing is to ask those relationships to lever their trust of one
another,
to start to start a disciple making micro group where they can begin to become a
little bit more transparent, where they can become accountable to one another.
They can share responsibility for spiritual growth. And lastly, uh,
I want you to be able to inform your, uh, community group about our webpage.
And that is hhbc.com/disciple.
There you can go and say, I want to be discipled, or I want to make disciples.
And lastly,
you can give an update about the micro groups that are started in your community
group. I know that this is a very,
very important role and I know that there are a lot of community groups that
don't have someone in this, in this, um, in this role.
But I wanna encourage you that if you can, uh,
leverage the relationships in your community group and you can see those
relationships deepen and, uh, and and literally be, uh,
the asset that causes them to grow spiritually, uh,
it's gonna change your community group for the better and for the glory of God.